Why superiors is,
it's funny,
it's,
it's a little like the waves of grief.
I think you have waves of awareness.
Um,
and one of the things that I found with
grief was actually I was well,
well prepared for it by the cyclicity of
my manic depressive illness and because
I was used to things coming and going,
um,
and so forth.
So I think that my awareness of having a
bipolar is really,
you know,
have 17,
I got very,
very depressed and I was like
[inaudible] I didn't have any energy and
it was totally,
I just,
but I didn't have the words.
People didn't talk about it at that
time.
And people that certainly didn't have
the words bipolar Ellis or manic
depressive poles.
So I just was terrified.
Um,
I had no idea what had happened to me
and I was very frightened and I was
frightened it would come back.
But I got well and then I did what
everybody or most people do when they
get well.
I sort of put it behind me again and
then it would come and hit me again and
again.
And so I knew there was something wrong.
Um,
I started to see a psychiatrist,
tried to see a psychiatrist when I was
in college and I ended up just running
away and I couldn't tolerate the idea of
doing that.
Um,
but then when I was,
I actually got my degree and I,
I joined the medical school faculty at
Ucla.
I became raving Lee Manic and very
psychotic and hallucinating,
delusional.
I didn't have any choice.
And it was the gray.
It's the great advantage of having an
illness as severe as mine is that you
are automatically brought into the
medical care system if you have until as
long as it was milder,
I could kind of get by with actually
having to face what was the severity of
my problem.
And I,
I knew the person I wanted to see.
It was somebody I had trained with.
He was my clinical supervisor and I had
seen him with patients and I had seen
that he was tough and smart and
compassionate and humanists,
but also new science and in medicine.
And so I went to him terrified and he
was just absolutely ferman his
diagnosis.
He just never wavered.
Um,
and he just said that's the way it is.
But he was kind about it,
but he didn't back off from it.
And he was a great psychotherapist.
And so one of the things I've tried to
do in my professional life,
like a lot of my colleagues,
is to emphasize,
you know,
medications just aren't enough for many
people who have these illnesses because
exactly what you're saying is how do you
become aware of an illness?
You become aware of an illness by
understanding yourself and understanding
the meaning that that illness has in
your own life symbolically and more
importantly,
quite literally.
I've primarily been in the psychotic
when manic,
uh,
which is not uncommon with mania.
And,
um,
it's been mostly when I've been manic,
it's been a very exhilarating sort of
thing,
including the hallucinations.
Um,
I went around the solar system,
I went to Saturn.
I,
in my mind's eye,
I went through the star fields.
It was,
it was a glorious,
are ecstatic experience,
which is frequently the case with mania.
When you think about a lot of the great
religious ecstasies is a very manic
quality to that and a very grandiose and
they tend to be very universal,
cosmic related to everything's related
to everything.
Um,
but I also had some very bad ones.
I've,
you know,
I'm hallucinating myself is dead or as
I'm just covered with blood,
I mean mania is,
can be as terrifying as it gets.
It is certainly as insane as one gas.
And so it's,
it's frightening when it gets out of
control,
but there are periods of mania where it
can be extremely attractive.
Unfortunately,
probably true
in depression.
Your capacities you feel just flattens
and disappears and what you feel is
pain.
Um,
and,
and it kind of paint that you can't
describe to anybody.
So he is,
so it's an isolating pain.
I can put the isolating pain.
Um,
it's for people with bipolar roles in
particular.
Um,
it is a,
a deadening,
um,
lethargy in a coupled with an agitation
and restlessness at times,
but it's a sense of having no energy,
no interest on no passion in their life.
And so for me,
like everybody else who gets to really
depressing,
you know,
there comes a point when you say,
okay,
if I,
if I can't feel,
if I can't care,
if I can't think,
I can't concentrate,
I can't remember.
I can't read.
Um,
if I can't love,
where am I?
Who is in there?
Where's the humanity?
It's gone.
And,
um,
the pain is agonal adjust is
unrelenting.
In my case,
I had stopped my medicine,
my looked at him and I gotten a wildly
manic and then I got paralytics be
depressed for 18 months and there was
not a time during those 18 months,
I can remember feeling okay.
And at some point I tried to kill
myself.
And I think again,
it's very hard to describe the kind of
pain that goes on in severe depression
because it's just,
the words are not there.